aber egal wir kriegen das schon
irgendwie hin dass alles zu regeln und
dann wird eventuell in ein paar tagen
oder morgen schon captain einfach zwei
start
[Musik]
hallöchen freuen und willkommen zurück
zur capt minecraft wir sind ein wenig
nach draußen gegangen weil es im moment
heißt es bei uns ich weiß nicht für
gratis bei euch ja gerade weniger aber
es war sogar ein tag 34 35 grad war es
immerhin 30 grad und jetzt kommt ist das
wahrscheinlich eine woche oder zwei
wochen schon wieder her nicht die
sexuelle die momentane am start ist
werden wir gerade den 19
kann man ja mal sagen ja wir sind
nämlich am vorproduzieren bla bla bla
und wir haben jetzt halt ein bisschen
gewartet der server selbstverständlich
an geblieben und das ist jetzt alles ein
bisschen gewachsen das heißt da das
jetzt meine folge ist ich mache das man
mit dem zauberte schneller folge auch
mal was erreichen wo es endlich schafft
damals ein erfolg wenn gomez folge habe
ich denn das mit kuchen übrigens
geschafft hat ist das ganze wie ein
weitergegangen hätte das sehen wollt
dass bei gomez dann schnappe ich mir
jetzt eben noch das leder wichtig ihnen
überholmanöver seien selbstverständlich
einen erfolgen bald manche ja auch eine
wunderschöne 14 stimme verwahrte ich
habe ein buch heute noch zwei diamanten
und saphir obsidian die zwei diamanten
habe ich vier ob sie die anrufe dafür
brauchen wir die amag sagte hab ich hier
passt du okay
bist du bereit komme für den humba humba
tanz zuschauer
seid ihr bereit für den home button
breit nächsten erfolg aber in dem musst
du ja machen verdammt welchen ok wat ich
schau mal ganz kurz was ich jetzt
ergeben schwertmeister des kampfes
benötigt
ich glaube die mutter hat die am rad
schwertmeister des kampfes verursache
acht herzen schaden mit einem einzigen
schlag
ja also schwer zu verzaubern mich
schlagen fertig also diamant schmerzen
sonst wäre ja kein diamant schwert ich
mache mir da mal kurz 1 0 machen dann
schlägst mich einfach und danach liegen
die rüstung lasse ich mal am besten
dafür auch aus
wir kommen hat ein bisschen schluckauf
gerade wir brauchen holzmann den ganzen
tag irgendwie seitdem wir oft um haben
im abi schluckauf irgendwie da geht gar
nicht mehr weg
bei mir und pflanzen macht die bäume
hoch betagt oder hat das können wir mal
machen das parlament starten so du
erklärst immer was man gegen schluckauf
tun kann nicht probiert es aus
hau dir fünf mal gegen den kopf aber ich
weiß ich noch nicht
vielleicht aber sie ist nicht weg sechs
mal gegen den kopf hauen da ist das
mache ich weil ich zwei finger in die
nase stecken
das macht ich kenne ja auch den
richtigen trick gegen schluckauf als
diese einen trick und zwar müsst ihr
selber kopf sein und dann müsst ihr
wasser so trinken sogar kopf und das ist
das einzige holz ist wieder diese blöde
ringen das ist das einzige was ich weiß
da was dagegen hilft ja mein tipp der
auf jeden fall hilft dass folgender
wasser und luft anhalten und dann wenn
die kaum noch könnt also wenn die luft
schon bald fast weg ist dann müsst ihr
das auch unterstützen allerdings weg
kann man mir in den minuten dauern aber
ich will da kannst du alleine grund wenn
ich wenn du eine frage mich hat sich
nick dann immer ja und zwar
wenn du ins weg bis g mal auf den
verzaubert tisch da sind zwei dinge die
man da machen kann ich glaube es braucht
dafür smaragde oder ich dachte können
sich antworten auf dich wartet ich bin
mal ganz ohne texture pack nenne ich hab
noch mal unterbrochen handy ich hab da
was
also ich kann sein spott wo das ist
natürlich jetzt panne wenn wir einen
gewinn texture pack erfolge haben die
wallonie das ist ein bisschen komisch
ich muss ja lapislazuli reinlegen wovon
redest du vom verzaubert ich hab schon
begriffen
ich hab schon du kannst wieder dann
trägt da mach ich okay okay leute mal
sauber klaphake jetzt auch wieder mal in
meinen zwecks rein damit ihr da nicht
meckert hiervon wegen der hilfen
schreckliche ich war jetzt hier ein
schwert rein das meine ich nämlich dass
das noch nicht so gearbeitet wurde aber
trotzdem jeder ich habe schärfe 1 und
rückstoß blablabla ich schlag dich mal
wahrscheinlich viele herzen dort abzug
das macht ne ich finde dass abgezogen
schreibt ein chat viereinhalb ok ich
muss acht herzen abziehen von jemandem
ich kann das aber glaub ich nicht normal
verzaubern oder
ich kann es nicht normal verzauberte das
ist ja echt blöd wieso kann ich ja nicht
weiter verzaubern
ich könnte mir verzaubern
ich habe allerdings raus tex mex
haha komme ich kann ich mir verzaubern
ja nee ich kann jetzt erklären und zwar
ganz normal also wenn das schwert einmal
verzaubert ist geht es nicht nochmal
darauf ist packt ich habe dann aber über
umwege geht es nochmal wenn man ein
amboss baut und dann bücher verzaubert
das geht ja man kann ja bücher
verzaubern oder meinetwegen zwei mal
schärfer 1 nebeneinander ein amboss
legen und das schwert ich habe aber wenn
jemand stellt jetzt schon verzaubert er
genau dann müssen wir jetzt um zweiter
zu verzaubern
dings was soll ich sagen in sapporo und
bücher kräften aber wir haben nicht so
viel reisen
das ist halt das problem nummer zwei
wenn man nicht so viel zucker für bücher
das ist problem immer teil bei das
nächste tief in was wir da unten auch
noch haben neben dem zauber tisch ist
der dass man mit diesem biblioteca ich
kann das nicht lesen aber dafür braucht
man wahrscheinlich auch ich schaue mal
ganz groß bücherregal wahrscheinlich ein
bauer bücherregale um deinen zauber
tisch zu verbessern
da müssen wir nur warten auf das
zuckerrohr und das seit ewigkeiten ich
kann noch mal eben neues ans tanzen also
wir haben hier noch ein bisschen sand ja
jetzt so langsam ist ja ob mann oder
frau ist weg aber gleich kommt daher
weil ich wieder lachen
so warte aber ich denke dass so langsam
ist es wirklich so dass man bei vielen
erfolgen aufwarten muss man jetzt gerade
das ist ein ganz erfolge sind nochmals
als du mir geschrieben könne das projekt
er so lange machen sagt dem motto wie
wir auch gut vorankommen so waren jetzt
auch dadurch spaß macht ja ich weiss
nicht also es gibt einen teil 2 und den
haben wir beide natürlich schon entdeckt
vor einer woche ja und ok eigentlich
also das projekt auch gestartet haben
wir haben gedacht wir spielen teil 1
zuerst weil das natürlich sehr sinnvoll
wenn man die zeit verfliegt aus dem
unlogisch deswegen habe gesagt wir
fangen mit teil 1 an
wir haben ein paar fehler gemacht das
muss man sagen wir haben außer sehen die
ersten direkt getötet war hat sich das
war ja gar nicht ich das war das war der
tintenfische
ein paar sage einfach falsch gemacht so
auch jetzt irgendwie weiß nicht was er
mir noch falsch gemacht
viele leute eigentlich ja wir haben in
gold apfel falsch gebaut
aber jetzt da das so eine sache
wir konnten die ganze map untergrabe
aber dann hätten wir bestimmt das ganze
gold nur das wird immens lange dauern
und ihr werdet das bestimmt feiern also
ihr würdet bestimmt sagen hey kommen das
doch ball cool wenn ihr das alles macht
und so das projekt ist doch super cool
wir finden das ja auch cool und macht
das ja auch spaß und alles aber es ist
halt so dass zurzeit was wollte ich
überhaupt sagen ich bin grad schon
wieder relativ polo wolf schon vier gold
blöcke wollte es gerade darauf
wahrscheinlich habe den freund wolf 2
irgendwie genau spricht und zwar
mittlerweile wenn jemand ich gehe mal
ganz kurz dieser folge hierdurch will
kann das ja mal anschauen darum haben
wir alle wir müssten jetzt um meister
des kampfes zu schaffen müsste ich
müsste mir einen amboss bauen und für
diesen brauchen wir glaube ich drei
eisen und vier eisen blöcke wir alle
sind blöcke oder drei alten blöcke jetzt
halt ein eisen blog allein schon besteht
aus neun reise und ich hatte gerade
schon probleme unten überhaupt mal drei
eisen zu finden
also das wird immens lange dauern dann
besiegte ein gas derzeit eigenen waffen
den haben wir geschafft das ende das
ende finden hatte ja schon vielleicht
ist es frei gesetzt ihr stimmt stimmt
das können wir schon die wahl doch doch
durch du hast recht es geht mir gerade
ums prinzip und zwar die ganzen erfolge
die jetzt kommt dafür hohe alter alter
ich gehe da und hab mein gott kommen
jetzt mal wieder hoch da sind drei
jahren gewesen
ich könnte aber das in drei hexen
gewesen ich bin mal kurz mal weg da rein
ich versuche mal ganz kurz weiter zu
kommentieren das kann relativ krass hier
es geht ums prinzip und zwar sind die
ganzen erfolge jetzt nur noch aufwarten
aufgebaut wir müssen total lange auf das
super robot wir müssen die ganze welt
aus höheren um neues geld zu bekommen
und eisen und alles mögliche deswegen
haben wir uns gedacht werden dass wir
haben uns schon vor einer woche gesagt
ich hab' eisen gefunden
okay wir haben uns schon vor einer woche
gesagt wenn das projekt zu diesem teil
an dem wohl nur noch suchen muss und
alles möglich und nicht mehr unbedingt
so nicht mehr den spielspaß richtig da
ist dann wollen wir skeptisch minecraft
zwei start und mit unserer erfahrung
skeptisch minecraft 1 wird das ganze
wahrscheinlich viel viel mein gott ich
habe mich eingebaut mit allgemein haus
wo mein gott denke mir was du willst
nicht sehen wo ich gerade bin
wir sind ich habe noch nie so viele mops
auf einem haufen gesehen die sind alle
in so einem kleinen raum gespannt recht
wo mein gott ist das krass oh mein gott
ist das irre
das ist ja nicht mehr normal ist mal
ganz kurz ich hab mir einen kleinen weg
hier hoch gebaut
jetzt will ich mir auch mal gucken
wollte mir gleich gedacht waren eltern
sind der kaputt aber ich ich könnte
jetzt da unten alle monster halter das
ist ja nicht mehr normal
das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen so
viele machen hoffen ich hoffe erstmal
ganz kurz das eisen jetzt meine
spitzhacke noch ganz besonders aber auch
bei mir wir unterkommen wenn du möchtest
dass meine schwester ist gut klagte ich
jetzt erstmal kurz dahinter das ist ja
nicht mehr normal
für viele mag ich auch schon lange nicht
mehr auf dem boden gesehen geht mir aber
hier gerade auch also so viele wie hier
hatte ich auch schon lange nicht mehr
auch wir sind genau gleich wie du willst
und was ich an den deutschen raum k
seien über dem dungeon runde ein
bisschen alter alle sind tot
was geht hier ab macht alle sind tot
heißt die reihe waren hier voll am
kämpfen jeder und wertvoll das thema
wieder mit dem thema wie im film
der junge war das krass da ist sie ganz
mops da gesehen habe ich gesehen darüber
weiter runter und gucken genau wir
wollten noch ein wir wollten noch mehr
an den tischen und dass die leute ja
auch schon wieder kaputt
die wartezeiten vor ein paar wir haben
durch dieses projekt was ich jetzt
eigentlich sagen wollte viel gelernt so
dass man vorsichtig mit allen sachen
umgehen muss wir haben beispielsweise
direkt die akku getötet
wir haben beispielsweise direkt gedacht
ok kommen da ist ne kuh wir töten die
mal war dann bekommen wir haben so nicht
nachgedacht ok kommen vielleicht sollten
und wenn eine andere kuh kommt dass wir
die dann fahren oder irgend sowas so
weit haben wir nicht nachgedacht
deswegen
deswegen atx index aex ich bin verliebt
ich bin verliebt ich bin verliebt bin
fertig ganz schwer
ich habe das geld auch noch getötet ok
komme ich halte wieder das ist rang nur
ich beende das hat man ganz kurz war
wir haben uns gedacht dass wir jetzt
minecraft kämpfte frankreich 2 starten
wollen wenn das ganze projekt diesen
teil annimmt dass man nur noch wartet
auf zuckerrohr wartet auf banken
so wartet auf weiß nicht was man gold
findet dass man reisen findet sondern
ganze geld die bringt nicht nur auf ein
halbes herunter also du kannst nicht den
stürmen okay gut und das jetzt würden
wir euch fragen ob ihr wollt das
verkappte von minecraft zwei staaten mit
unserem neuen wissen was wir durch
dieses projekt gelernt haben wie das man
vorsichtig mit allem umgehen sollte
dass wir direkt von anfang an nicht uns
irgendein ekligen gang runter bauen
sondern vielleicht alles direkt mit der
leiter machen vielleicht auch das mit
den hühnern war ich gut finde haben wir
super gemacht mit dem essen
das muss ich echt sagen das haben wir
gut hingekriegt das war ich da wirklich
nie helfen diesen problemen oder
hinbekommen das war richtig gut ihr
würdet die welt dann auch
selbstverständlich zum download bekommen
wir würden die hochladen ihr könntet ihr
den download und eventuell vielleicht
auch weiterspielen ich weiß es nicht
und wie ich wird halt jetzt euch fragen
weil ich denke eigentlich dass also ich
bin auf jeden fall dafür das wetab das
minecraft zwei jetzt machen vielleicht
noch ja ich weiß nicht wie wir müssen
mal schauen wie ich mich denn jetzt
eigentlich auch keine spitzhacke weiß
ich nicht aber ich genau nicht jetzt
eine noch lange nicht warte ich mach das
jetzt mal ganz kurz hier unten so ein
bisschen machen uns schon so eine kleine
base dannenberg banken mache jetzt
immerhin rät du mal ganz kurz weiter nee
und auf jeden fall gerade auch captain
minecraft 2 hat natürlich noch mal viele
neue elemente die alle sehr interessant
auf jeden fall von den fotos und so
weiter her ausland vom video auf youtube
denn dazu gab es auch ein trailer und
ich hätte wirklich allein schon die
haben ein leben blöcke verwendet jeder
der mich kennt weiß okay ich liebe leben
blöcke oder land deswegen ins camp der
einkauf 2 bei mir sehr hoch angesehen
und für mich war gehabt auf minecraft 1
auch eine richtig coole erfahrung
einfach mal wären diese lage mit den
schiffen ins rennen zu kommen und ich
denke mir jetzt wissen wir auf jeden
fall okay was kann man denn machen
was gibt's denn so viel schöner archiv
menz und so weiter wir kennen halt schon
so ein wenig den ablauf und können
wahrscheinlich in einem neuen projekt
wenn wir jetzt captain minecraft zugang
zu ihrem heim rennen genau da können wir
einfach wie konnte oft hatten sie schon
oft sagte halt einfach unser komplettes
wissen darauf an wänden und ein richtig
cooles neues projekt starten obwohl ich
auch so ein wenig sagen muss ich weiß
nicht ob es genau so nach dem motto das
gleiche wird weil man könnte denken okay
kräfte von craft 2 ist auch das gleiche
die eher tief wenn es jedoch auch
eigentlich an sich die komplett gleichen
aber ich habe da also von den videos ja
und so wie ich da gesehen habe das war
alles schon etwas schwieriger
falls ja auch alles das skeptisch
mannschaft zwei das hier ist wirklich
einfach nur so eine welt die so ein
bisschen so wertig eine normale welt war
einfach sein ding runter gezogen wird
bike exif minecraft 2 gibt es einen
trailer der einem zeigt das ist der
autor das ist da wirklich das ist custom
gemacht also das ist einfach wirklich
hergestellt dieses terrain da sind extra
blöcke überall versteckt da sind sogar
das ist die doppelte minecraft höre das
ist doppelt so groß wie das ganze hier
das geht quasi von ganz oben bis nach
ganz unten dass es irgendwie nicht weil
sie nicht wenn das jetzt 120 blöcke sind
ist dass da irgendwie 240 blöcke sondern
nach dem motto das ist halt doppelt so
groß da sind dungeons das sind richtige
railway gänge oder wie das heißt
da sind richtig richtig viele coole
sachen hinzugefügt werden auch so ein
bisschen story gebunden weil man da
monumente findet und dann kriegt man da
durch türen geöffnet und alles mögliche
das jetzt richtig cool und wir müssen
eigentlich gar nicht mehr viel sagen
wenn ihr solche angucken wollte kann
jetzt einfach selber machen der link ist
ja immer in der beschreibung der website
da seht ihr kind das minecraft 2 ich
mache mal anderen vorschlag wenn ihr
wollt dass wir das spielen und ihr lasst
dadurch dann auch noch kennen lernt ihr
müsst euch ja nicht unbedingt
irgendwelche 964 sw stellen das dann vor
wenn ihr bock darauf habt dann schreibt
dass man gerne in die kommentare
genau und dann stellen wir das vorspiel
das noch so sein also ihr müsst jetzt
nicht sagen okay komm ich will dass ich
hab das 2 spielt aber dann dauert das
bestimmt in der nähe
das wird nämlich dann direkt jetzt die
tage losgehen morgen nämlich
ne also wenn jetzt wollt wenn ich die
kommentare lest dann machen wir uns dran
und machen sie morgen dann in folge
dafür fertig werden das dann versuchen
dann wirklich alles so direkt im
sauberen übergang hinzubekommen
aber wir müssen auch jetzt vorweg sagen
bevor zu später wieder alles mögliche
vorgeworfen wird also von mir aus ich
sage es mal so ich bin bei gleichen
philosophie wie bei der karten möchte
kein let's play machen wo ich irgendwie
stundenlang auf dem zuckerrohr warte ja
deswegen rohstoffe wir machen das so
lange wie wir halt aktiv davor ankommt
was halt dieser spaßfaktor dran ist aber
wir warten müssen
dann kann es auch sein dass wir das
projekt nicht komplett mit erhalt und
die installation zu sein das rezept
gemeinschaft 2 dann direkt nach 5 platz
beenden
dass ich gerade dadurch dass wir haben
hier richtig richtig viel gelernt und
deswegen dass wir gerade da so wissen ok
kommen wenn das land sind dann töten wir
die selbstverständlich mit der hand vom
islam ball zu kriegen ich weiß ja wie
die da vielleicht hilft uns brauchen wir
wissen noch gar nicht wie das dann wird
deswegen das ist halt eine neue
herausforderung aber die behindern
direkt wenn ihr das wollt ihr leben das
war gerade im voraus auf und kann eure
kommentare nicht lese aber wir können
noch mal bei twitter schreiben und euch
da fragen und alles und ich denke ich
dass viele dafür sein werden weil die
unsere meinung darauf versteht und ich
denke mal
man merkt es uns bei noch an wir beide
sind richtig heiß auf das teil wir beide
haben selber mega bock drauf das ding zu
spielen denn noch immer hat nämlich auch
schon als wir
captain minecraft 1 als wir im zehnten
partnern oder so hat er schon
geschrieben alter lasse auf jeden fall
nach entspricht irgendwie das eigene
produkt als ob das unsere eigene karte
wir so vertreten müssen so aber wir
haben die idee ist einfach hammer
wirklich die jetzt richtig gut mit
dieser world order mit ski fans und was
man halt nicht eigentlich auf einem auf
ein blödes vor umgehen muss und gucken
was okay das und das da hat man mal so
im raum mannschaft drin ja eben das ist
ein traum
ohne witz also ich hab mich drauf und
wir werden euch dann und gerade halt mal
auf twitter fragen und auf jeden fall
könnt ihr auch in die kommentare
schreiben zu dem thema denkt zum thema
gesagt sie könnten noch viel mehr zu
sagen
und darauf freuen aber ich würde sagen
der eisglatten glaube ich bin wenn ihr
wollt dass wir es machen dann schreibt
es einfach wenn wir den blick soll dann
wir schreiben das ist jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen komisch weil wir gerade im
voraus produzieren wenn wir dann bei
twitter posten aber egal wir kriegen das
schon irgendwie hin dass alles zu regeln
und dann wird eventuell ein paar tagen
oder morgen schon 52 staaten da werdet
ihr wieder eine folge auf beiden kanälen
sehen damit beide kanäle leute das
wissen dass es losgeht und natürlich
sagen was euch trotzdem gefallen hat und
zeigt es uns mit einem mag ich und dann
sehen wir uns wieder in captain
minecraft 2